[Music]
all right let's go welcome to another
speedrun game we're going to do a 10 uh
10-minute game for those watching on
YouTube it is a little bit late I've
been streaming for a while and when we
do 10-minute games I'm generally a
little bit more to the point during the
game itself and then after the game I
really spell out some of my thought
processes because I just don't have the
time to do it quite like I do and it's
15 plus 10 so we're going to play a
Kings Indian I've switched completely to
my real opening repertoire at this later
stage of the speedrun okay so Knight C3
is the entry point to the jababa London
or the Barry system we want to play D5
here to prevent white for move ordering
us into a perk which for the purposes of
this speedrun we do not play and we have
transposed into the jababa London or as
the old name is the the berry system I
think the berry system is specifically
the jababa system kind of against the G6
setup okay so we start by fing our
Bishop E3 this is all very standard Fair
let's complete our kingside development
with castles and Bishop B2 white plays
it in a very kind of quieter uh Tamer
manner um after the game I'll show you
what uh my recommendation is in the
jababa London it it's connected with an
early Pawn push so white has a very
positional way of playing this system
and a very tactical way of playing this
system and white is playing it much more
strategically much more quietly so black
has a million different ways to disarm
the berry system I'm going to play in a
very kind of solid straightforward
manner um I think we're going to start
with the move C6 just solidifying the
center in some situations preparing
Queen B6 and white actually does play H4
so he's combining two different ideas on
the one hand was playing Bishop B2 to
fool me into a false sense of security
and then suddenly launching the attack
with H4 okay very dangerous so how are
we going to respond to this well the
typical method is to play H5 stopping
the progress of White's H Pawn so let's
go H5 Knight
E5 okay in some situations preparing a
quick G4 we have to get this Knight off
the board ASAP so Knight bd7 is pretty
standard in this position yeah otherwise
white sometimes very quickly plays G4
and crashes through on the king side and
before we know it we could get
checkmated now if white plays G4 my
intention is Knight takes E5 D takes E5
Knight takes G4 so we're in time to
eliminate the G Pawn while keeping the
king side intact okay so typically
jababa London players like to keep the
tension in a position like this and make
a move like Queen D2 of course once
white plays H4 it becomes very evident
that in 99% of cases white is going to
Castle Queen side so we're going to get
an opposite side castling type position
with attacks on both sides of the board
F3 very good move preparing G4 our
opponent is demonstrating fantastic
knowledge of typical ideas in the system
okay so what are we going to do now we
can play Queen B6 and hit the B2 Pawn
that comes to mind uh we can position
the queen also on A5 we could release
the tension and trade on E5 and try to
trade as many pieces as possible I'm
going to implement a Crea idea we're
going to take on
E5 and one of the drawbacks of the move
F3 of course is that it creates a
weakness on E3 this Pawn is now a
weakness and I'm going to play a pretty
unconventional move Bishop to H6 which
within the framework of just attacking
the E3 Pawn should make a lot of sense
to this Pawn has become weak so we're
deploying our Bishop and attacking it
but generally uh a lot of players find
it kind of awkward to move your Bishop
away from mitzan kto spot and often
times it is kind of oddly odd to put
your Bishop on H6 but in this case I
think it makes a lot of sense especially
because if white pushes E4 then in the
future White's going to have a very hard
time castling Queen side because our
Bishop is going to be holding C1 so I
think E4 is way over ambitious if white
plays Queen D2 which is the standard way
of defending the pawn then our Bishop is
going to be exerting rather nasty
long-term pressure on this de
diagonal okay Queen D2 is played Queen
D2 is played so we need to take this
opportunity and prepare for the case in
which White Castle Queens side which I
think is likely to be our opponent's
next move well if White Castle's Queens
side then ideally we would want to
develop something resembling an attack
on the queen side so preemptively I
think a move that might discourage white
from castling Queen side is B5 just
throwing our pawns down the board and
trying to it's kind of like in baseball
what's the term when you're um when
you're leading and you've stepped away
from the base kind of preparing for the
pitch to happen th this is what I would
compare B5 to of course white has not
castled Queen side yet so if white
doesn't Castle Queen side then B5 might
seem like a useless move but it's not a
very harmful move it also grabs space on
the queen side we're not really making
any concessions by playing B5 but if
white does Castle Queen side then we get
an extra Tempo we've already gotten our
attack started if that makes sense and
every Tempo is crucial in a situation
where the kings are castled to opposite
sides of the board because presumably
White's going to try to get G4 going and
then things are going to get really
really crazy so we have no time to waste
we have no time to waste yeah I don't
even watch baseball I just think that
might have been a relatable analogy to
some people yeah to lead off I think is
the term so our opponent is taking their
time Bishop D3 nice move move I'm
assuming that they're preparing to meet
with Knight E2 that's a very highle move
okay so what are the options here we can
drop our own Knight back to D7 and try
to get rid of this annoying Bishop then
Bishop F4 we can trade on F4 and try to
ruin White's Pawn structure we can do
something much more tactical like a move
like C5 just leading to complete
pandemonium on the board I like
pandemonium so not the worst option in
the world
we can play B4 Knight E2 and then
C5 aha so that actually might not be
such a bad option B4 Knight E2 and then
C5 just trying to stake as big of a
claim in the center as possible Knight
D7 Bishop F4 Bishop G7 to prepare E5 is
also very interesting then we have to
reckon with G4 E5 takes takes G takes H5
looks a little bit risky I don't like it
Knight D7 Bishop F4 Bishop F4 e takes F4
also looks pretty sterile okay so in
that case in that case let's go crazy
let's go B4 chasing away the Knight and
also forcing our opponent to make a
decision yeah Knight E2 and now the
followup C5 so first of all why did we
start with B4 well first of all we
wanted to expand on the queen side
second of all we were threatening C4
which would trap the bishop there C3 so
our opponent is playing this kind of
like a London system I'm going to take
on C3 in order to fully discourage white
from castling Queens side so what we've
essentially done is we've opened up the
queen side and we now have prevented
white from being able to Castle to this
side of the board which would now be
complete Madness uh because the B file
is open and it's going to be very very
easy for us to get to White's King now
we're going to implement the second idea
that I mentioned Knight back to D7 and
we're going to try to open up the center
why am I trying to open up the center
now well because White's King is kind of
stuck in the center white can Castle
King side but then the H4 Pawn is going
to be a major liability white can Castle
Queen side but as I've already mentioned
it's going to be very very easy to pick
off White's King in that case if white
gets stuck in the center and we're able
to open the center up um then we're
going to be able to ultimately get to
White's King this is what I'm trying to
do by dropping my knight back to D7 and
now my Bishop back to its initial F and
GTO Square we are trying to prepare E7
E5 which would completely blast open the
center it would also open up the
diagonal for our Bishop and I think it
would lead to very very positive
consequences Rogue D1 so clearly our
opponent is aware of what our idea is
and he is trying to discourage us from
pushing E5 do we want to push E5 anyway
or do we want to make another
Preparatory move well that's a good
question so what happens if we play E5 D
takes E5 Knight takes E5 there is this
weird move Bishop E4 uh in that position
and that D5 Pawn is going to crumble a
little bit so maybe we want to prepare
E5 for one more move yeah I think we
want to go Bishop B7 we want to go
Bishop B7 which may seem stupid if taken
in isolation like why are we putting the
bishop on a square where it's just
biting on granite but in light of the
line that I just spelled out this move
should make sense to after we push E5
and the trade happens we want to make
sure that the D5 Pawn isn't a soft
target uh for White's heavy pieces along
the default okay G4 now things are going
to really really heat up and now I'm
going to have to play silently very very
likely because things are going to get
very very tactical takes
H5 then we can push E5 it feels really
good for black uh we can also start with
E5 but then after takes takes takes
takes G takes H5 feels really scary so
we could get checkmated here I'm not
completely not um ruling out the
possibility that we get mated but if I
play accurately I hope that that's not
going to happen because now we're
opening up the center we are striking
away at White's very well protected Pawn
on D4 and now things are really really
heating up time situation is totally
fine we've got four minutes that's
plenty of time and we're forcing our
opponent to make another decision okay
Bishop G3 excellent now we could play
Rook E8 and keep the tension we could
snap off a pawn but I'm going to go with
my gut here I'm going to go with my gut
and we're going to play Rook E8 just
kind of keeping the tension and
obviously preparing to play e takes D4
in some cases putting the rook in an
x-ray with the King Castle's King side
okay so our opponent is clearly like
abandoning his Ambitions of checkmating
us on the king side and instead
prioritizing King safety which is
probably the right thing to
do yeah I kind of underestimated that
move wow okay so takes takes Knight F6
maybe we could go Knight F6 straight
away that actually might be a really
smart
alternative yes I really like the
straight the immediate Knight F6 there
are some tactics that stand behind this
move that I'll spell out after the game
obviously Bishop takes E5 is probably
what most people have their eyes on and
you're probably wondering what happens
if white simply snaps this Pawn off the
board okay G5 um Knight
G4 comes to mind Knight H5 also makes
sense so what happens Knight G4 maybe D
takes C5 mm Knight H5 or Knight G4 okay
have to start playing a little faster
here yeah let's go Knight G4 trying to
go after the E3 Pawn trying to go after
the E3 Pawn Maybe Knight H5 and queen D7
would have been a better idea but
whatever it's too late yeah Knight G4
probably a mistake would be my guess but
still I don't think such a bad
move Bishop B5 okay fantastic so we can
play e takes D3 or E uh e takes D4 but
what is the purpose of that why can't we
just calmly bring our Rook up to E7 also
solidifying the F7 Pawn which is very
valuable okay he takes the pawn very
good now it would be very nice to win
this Pawn back how can we do that well
we can do it with the queen queen C7 or
queen C8 I think makes the most sense
let's go Queen C8 and there are more
tactics that hide behind this move now
if white pushes
C6 then after the trade on C6 white is
unable to take on D5 at the end of the
line because after the trade we'll pick
up the pawn on E3 with a fork so that's
actually the reason that I didn't play
Rook C8 as I'll describe after the game
so I think White's position is very
close to falling apart because once we
pick up the pawn on C5 not only do we
have a fully intact Center and excellent
peace coordination both of our Bishops
are fan ketto but also White's pawns are
just so so weak here okay so he does
play C6 trading and Bishop F2 yeah but
now we're very close to being winning so
he wants to take on D5 let's make sure
that this Pawn is solidified let's go
Rook d8 protecting the D5 Pawn also
bringing the Rook into the game I'm
expecting E4 here and then we're going
to double up on the defile and try to
blast through in the center yeah black
is borderline winning here I just think
strategically because of how many
weaknesses white has in in their
position know this is just really really
good if I can keep my clock under
control I think I'm going to win I
should say we're going to win Royal we
Knight G3 okay very good E4 maybe yeah
E4 is a thought not sure it's the best
move but it does open up the bishop and
it also creates uh potential strongholds
for our Knight which can now Circle back
to E5 and then
ooh very juicy squares here okay let's
go Knight E5 very very juicy squares are
being accessed by our Knight and then
the queen can drive in along the white
squares as well looks like white is
starting to crumble here white is
starting to crumble yeah Knight F3
Outpost also hitting the pawn on H4
which we can capture with check and we
are going to capture this Pawn not
because it's a free Pawn but mainly
because also now the G5 Pawn is a huge
weakness and I'm seeing a mating
construction where the queen can get to
H3 okay so can we go Queen E6 here
doesn't even really matter we don't need
to engage in these complications we can
just simply go back to F3 okay I'm not
worried about anything that happens on
the H file because there's no attack so
now what we're going to do is we're
going to give a check the G5 Pawn is not
going anywhere so instead we're going to
go in for the kill we're going to deploy
Our Queen to G4 creating the possibility
for a future discovered attack against
White's Queen our Bishop is going to
come to E5 and put even more pressure on
the Knight and if necessary our King can
always Escape through the center okay
let's get the bishop involved Bishop B5
and I think White's resistance is coming
to an end because Rook G1 there's a
check on H3 that wins the
game yeah Rook G1 so obviously we're not
taking the rook and blundering our Queen
we are doing check and let's be accurate
here what is the accurate win let's
spend 30 seconds but make sure that we
don't give white any unnecessary chances
so I see at least two different ways to
win we can go Knight back to H4 but an
even more accurate way to win I think is
to play Bishop takes G3 and then Queen
H1 takes C1 as I've talked about many
many times before in the speedrun when
you're trying to finish off an attack
don't fixate on Checkmate very often you
can use the weakness of the King as a
springboard to winning material so often
the natural conclusion of a successful
attack is actually not mate uh per se
it's just like winning a decisive amount
of material I think the same thing goes
here so we have two ways to play here I
would try to cover the H file just to
make sure that nothing happens so we can
go Rook B7 and try to get the Rook to B2
but I really like the move I really like
the move King to G7 um just making sure
that we get the Rook to the H file and
then we get the other Rook over to the B
file so division of labor and eventually
a Checkmate is going to materialize a
Checkmate is going to materialize here I
think he might resign white literally
cannot move because of the presence of
this Knight okay so let's get one Rook
to the H
file and we're just a couple accurate
moves away from mate okay so we can go
Queen H1 Queen H4 that will finish the
game yeah let's do it White's going to
have to give up more material and we
have plenty of time
excellent and ultimately the Knight
decides the game and queen H4 is
literally just m we don't even have to
take back the
queeno okay yeah this is one of those
games that I think if you look at it if
you look through it very very quickly
you might come to the conclusion that it
was a pretty simple game we just kind of
outplayed our opponent but there was a
ton of tactical drama that kind of stood
behind the scenes and that is so often
the case in these high level games okay
90% accuracy pretty good let's open up a
new instance of the game I'm going to
put it into chess base so that we can
check the opening with an engine and off
we go so I know that people particularly
watching on YouTube you might have been
confused as to what exactly was kind of
happening in the middle game and toward
the end of the game I'll try to explain
everything as best I can uh because of
the reduced time control I didn't quite
have time to spell out all the
variations during the game hopefully
that's okay um okay so D4 Knight F6
Knight F3 G6 this is the entry point
to the Kings Indian defense and as a
king's Indian player you have to
remember not to pre Bishop G7 precisely
because there is this variation where
white plays Knight C3 in the jababa
London white plays Knight C3 on move two
you push D5 white plays Bishop F4 and
one of Black's main systems one that is
favored Often by Kings Indian players uh
is to play G6 and grunfeld players and
if white plays Knight F3 Bishop G7 E3 we
get exactly the position from the game
by transposition for for newer players
watching on YouTube uh the phrase
transposition just means the same
position happens but with two different
move orders in this case white played
Knight C3 first in the case of the
current game white played Knight F3
first but ultimately the same position
is reached uh that's what a
transposition is okay so Knight C3 D5 is
Bishop G7 a mistake it's not a mistake
but most people don't want to play the
PS if you are a PS player against E4 and
you like it uh then you don't really
have to learn the jababa lon you can
just play Bishop G7 and D6 but this is
relatively uncommon uh so for most
people it's more prudent uh to push D5
and prevent E4 okay so Bishop F4 uh the
Barry
system uh Bishop G7 obviously fing the
bishop and E3 so one important
clarification is that if white plays
this through the jababa move order
Knight C3 D5 Bishop F4 G6
uh in Sasha and my course we don't
recommend the move Knight F3 we actually
recommend E3 Bishop G7 and an early H4
trying to drive this Pawn down to H5 and
here you can see the benefit of delaying
the development of the Knight which is
that the link between the queen and the
H5 square is kept intact so H5 becomes a
very serious uh tactical threat uh and
often times it is supplemented with an
exchange sacrifice on H5 hopefully this
is an idea that you've seen before for
example if black plays a random move
white pushes H5 and after Knight takes
H5 sacrifices The Exchange and gets a
longterm attacking chances on the king
side and in the center in exchange for
the exchange and there are some really
really cool ideas uh in this dynamic
position like there's this idea C6 the
queen often drops back to H2 this is
often the best Square for the queen not
only because it's kind of out of the way
but still pressuring H7 but of course
also because there's this lovely idea
trapping the queen and White Castle's
Queen side yeah in these types of
positions white always castles Queen
side um which is a perfectly safe place
for White's King anyways this is a
different line uh you can check out our
course in this game white played the
more traditional move order um with
Bishop F4 E3 castles and Bishop E2 this
is how people used to play this in the
old days so essentially Black's setups
are divided into two categories the
principled move and probably the best
move for black is to push C5 this is the
move that you see uh across almost all
lines of the jababa London black pushes
C5 trying to punish white for bringing
the Knight out to C3 so in the
traditional London system the move C5 is
almost always met with C3 here white
does not have the move C3 so the D4 Pawn
is immediately Under Fire that's the
strategic justification for pushing C5
and of course you're almost never afraid
of T Tak C5 because this Pawn is very
easy to recover you can play Queen A5
and already the pawn is recovered on the
very next move Queen A5 the main move
here is actually Knight to D2 this is a
theoretical line Queen takes C5 Knight
to B3 this weird kind of maneuver Queen
C6 according to the engine in order to
make sure that D5 is protected eight
games in the database Castle's King side
including a very strong game
B6 preparing to Fen ketto Knight B5 and
there is a draw Knight B5 A6 Knight C7
Rook A7 Knight B5 with a three-time
repetition because if you play a takes
B5 white picks up B8 with interest so
black has to go back to A8 the computer
gives this weird
draw but this is not a particularly
theoretically topical Line This is just
one line that was pretty popular so
after
C5 the most popular move according to
the database is Knight to E5 just
putting the knight in the center our
opponent did this in the game and now
the computer really likes the move
Knight F to D7 increasing the pressure
on the E5 Knight it's obviously a pretty
unconventional move but the other Knight
is going to jump out to C6 and you're
essentially just trying to smoke the
Knight out as quickly as possible if
white plays Knight AK
D5 then you have Pawn takes D4 Pawn
takes D4 and suddenly this check is very
nasty forking the Knight and the king
the Knight is forced backward and you
very nicely win the pawn back here with
Bishop B5 D takes E5 you could even
throw in Rook to d8 with Tempo then you
pick up the pawn and black obviously has
absolutely no problems uh the Knight is
coming out to C6 no Knight fd7 is not an
engine move uh this is a pretty standard
idea because it it immediately increases
the pressure on the Knight it's just
important to recognize that Knight takes
D5 you have CD and queen A5 check that
can be hard to see if white plays Knight
takes D7 then you can play Bishop takes
D7 and here again if white plays Knight
takes D5 here you have Bishop C6 and a
lovely detail Knight C7 looks like it
wins The Rook black to play and find a
very typical and very important
idea very important idea that happens
when the Knight gets to C7 and there's a
bishop supporting it black to play and
win material yeah E5
interference and even though white is
able to take the Rook you obviously take
this bishop and then you're going to
come back and win the Knight probably
with B6 and Black's going to have two
pieces for a rook not to mention that
White's position is just collapsing here
uh because of the threat against G2 and
the threats along this diagonal as well
so just remember this idea of E5 white
can play Bishop E5 Bishop E5 and Knight
takes A8 probably a more Savvy way of
taking the Rook but here again takes
takes Bishop can drop back then you're
going to go B6 and you're going to pick
up the Knight or Knight to D7 so
anyways uh the tactics work out for
black in this position uh
2500 played Pawn takes C5 black can play
E5 occupying the center then very nicely
positioned this bishop on C6 and already
D4 is a serious threat black has a big
initiative and the C5 Pawn is ultimately
going to be recovered so the best move
is probably to push C5 but there's a lot
of theory involved here and I wasn't
really sure uh about the the
complications here I decided to play a
more solid move and there's nothing
particularly wrong with pushing C6 as
well and the point of pushing C6 is that
eventually we're going to prepare the
pawn break E7 E5 so if White Castles
kingside here my idea was to go Bishop
to G4 and let's say that white plays H3
and says thank you very much for the
bishop pair well after Bishop takes F3
Bishop takes F3 now we bring the Knight
out to D7 and we're almost ready to push
E5 on the next move we're likely to play
Rook E8 and then we're going to play E5
with an excellent position for example
Rook E1 we can already put play Rook E8
and everything is now ready for us to
play E5
um and once we play E5 everything is
kind of free the queen can come out to
B6 this is a more kind of positional
struggle but black is obviously not
worse here so that was my idea our
opponent played
H4 um probably with white I would play
Knight E5 or H3 to prevent Bishop G4 and
the computer does give a very small Edge
for white after H3 okay now it's giving
equality after Queen B6 no so so so C6
is a legitimate way to equalize the main
move is Knight E5 this is the most
popular move and here again black can go
Queen B6 just kind of tickling the pawn
forcing white to make an awkward
defensive move now we can play Knight
bd7 for example White
Castles and simply Knight takes E5
Bishop takes E5 then bring the other
Knight back to D7 and once again after
the trade the Smoke Clears and black is
ready to push E5 and you don't have to
worry about the quote unquote weakness
of the king because white is out of
pieces and White's castled to the king
side so the king is an absolutely no
danger here um so just a couple of
illustrative lines to show you how solid
Black's position is in these variations
our opponent uh took the game in a
completely different direction and went
for the old idea of H4 still quite a few
games in the database okay so we decided
to prevent the further progress of the
pawn of H5 on Knight E5 is the most
popular move over 50 games in the
database still and Knight be to E7
immediately contesting and challenging
the Knight and very importantly if white
pushes G4 we're able to play Knight
takes C5 and eliminate the G4 Pawn while
keeping our kingside Pawn chain intact
this is of course the critical question
because if you take G4 blindly then
you're allowing white to push H5 in the
future and everybody should know just
how dangerous this idea can be across
many many different types of openings uh
so our goal is to keep this Pawn chain
intact in order to make sure that our
King remains safe and that white does
not crash through on the king side so
our opponent continues to follow the
main line F3 still over 50 games in the
database and I'm seeing quite a few
strong uh strong OTB
games so we decided uh to trade on E5
main move Bishop takes E5 obviously Pawn
takes E5 is a terrible move
uh because this Pawn is well it's
immediately going to be lost after
Knight D7 so Bishop takes E5 is the
automatic recapture and Bishop
H6 which is the second most popular move
and the engine kind of likes it the most
popular move here is Knight to D7 which
I don't well Knight D7 is also fine I
guess Bishop takes G7 King takes G7 and
if white plays G4 here then we can
simply play H takes G4 F takes G4 and
now this very nasty move Queen C7 aiming
for G3 and white is just not able to get
the king out of the center in time this
check is very very nasty black can
follow it up with E5 and C clearly white
hasn't gotten off the ground on the king
side white just has not gotten off the
ground we're already opening up the
center black is doing completely fine so
Knight D7 would have been a totally
viable alternative which just shows you
that you shouldn't adhere to the Dogma
that you can never trade uh your fieno
Bishop just because your faneto Bishop
is gone doesn't automatically mean that
your king is in Mortal danger here white
just doesn't have the Firepower to make
anything happen on the king's side so
probably white should play the calmer
move Queen D2 and now we can just get
our Knight back to F6 to prevent G4 and
then our Queen can come up to D6 and we
can continue preparing E5 hopefully that
makes sense so there are many
Alternatives here we played Bishop
H6 white defends the pawn with Bishop
Queen D2 oh my God you will not believe
this but I have a game in the database
here I have a title Tuesday game from
2018 I was on the black side Ravi tja
versus nitzki October 2018 one of the
first title Tuesdays that I've ever
played in had this exact position so
that's how you know it's me and I
actually played the top engine
recommendation in that title Tuesday
game I played Knight D7 the bishop
dropped back to F4 and now what move did
I play in this position what would you
do here with black let's see who's been
paying attention uh to how I've
described Black's main ideas what should
black do here okay first of all the
bishop is hanging so don't say E5 yeah
the correct move is Bishop back to G7
and the reason is not because it's bad
to get rid of the bishop it's because a
owing white this bind is going to make
it almost impossible for you to push E5
and if you're not able to push E5 then
you're going to basically give white a
free hand on the king side and G4 is
already coming and it's going to be very
very unpleasant so what you want to do
is drop the bishop back to G7 that's
what happened in my game my opponent
played E4 and I responded with E5 and I
got a great position if white pushes G4
in this position then you can still play
E5 E5 5 D takes E5 throw in h takes G4
recapture on E5 and Black's got
excellent counterplay in the center and
it's very important to understand that
it's not that easy to Checkmate a king
that is protected by a fien ketto bishop
so for example if white plays H5 you can
even play Knight takes G4 and what
you're going to find is that in a
situation like this it's very very
difficult for white to actually get to
Black's King even though you've
succeeded opening up a lot of avenues
and the H file is open how are you
actually going to create threats against
Black's King it's much harder than it
sounds if you Castle Queen side well
then you've walked into a fork if you
play Bishop takes G4 and say aha I've
stacked my heavy pieces big deal I just
dropped my Bishop back to H5 and the
pawn very nicely protects the bishop
so so it's not enough just to push your
pawns forward you also have to have
pieces to follow it up with um and
that's why this setup is so effective
for black
anyways interestingly in that game I
played Bishop G7 or I played Knight D7
in this game I decided to start the
queenside operations with B5 still not a
novelty actually there's still a game in
the
database uh oh my God this is
unbelievable stunky versus nitzki
2011 oh my gosh I can't believe this I
was going to mention that game I was
going to mention that the first time
that I faced that I faced the Barry
system was against Alexander
stunky uh who's a grandmas from New
Jersey in the 2011 us championship and
we reached this exact position no
way so I've had this twice now no three
times now including this game here's the
stunky game the stunky game reached this
position with a slightly different move
order I mean I remember that game it's
just shocking to me that this was the
exact same position here's the stunky
game which I lost this was the last
round of the US Championship the very
first one I think that was held in St
Louis so as you can see he plays the
exact move order as in the game
C6 aha so Knight E5 Knight bd7 H4 there
we go H5 Queen D2 takes takes this is
the exact position no not yet
B5 F3 and Bishop H6 so completely
different move order here I played
Bishop H6 in this position and I
actually got a really nice position it
was a wild game I ended up losing it
yeah so here's that idea with Knight D7
and Bishop G7 I started attacking I got
a great position but eventually he
crushed me and it was just a wild game
it was just a wild tactical game but
eventually I lost um but wow that's
insane this is from 2011 and I didn't
remember that we got the exact same
position
unbelievable I mean what are the odds of
that the database told me yeah I
searched this position in the database
and it spit out shuni
nitzki
unbelievable that's honestly that's
honestly pretty mind-boggling uh so just
to be clear what I'm saying for people
on YouTube who might be lost as to what
I'm saying I'm running this position on
chess Bas and every time I make a move
it shows me the games that have reached
the primarily the over theboard games
but also the Blitz Games that have
reached this position and I'm I was
seeing two separate games like in this
position I was seeing one of my games
with Knight D7 and once I put B5 on the
board by transposition we reached the
game stun skin nit as well as one other
game from
2023 Safar versus deorov not a famous
game so Bishop D3 was played by shuni so
we're continuing to follow uh stunky
nitki and I played Knight D7 here
but in this game I decided to continue
my queenside attack with B4 and B4
according to the computer is not the
best move according to the computer I
should have played Knight D7 and Bishop
G7 just like I did against trunsky and
black is a great position here he played
Bishop G5 and here the best move would
have been F6 Bishop F4 and E5 so it's
good to know that I thought exactly the
same way in 2011 that I still do now
nothing has changed with my 15-year-old
self okay so in this game I played
before excuse me Knight E2 and
C5 um threatening C4 and trying to blast
open the center and trying to discourage
white from castling Queen side um if
white plays D takes C5 then I was
intending to drop my knight back to D7
forking the bishop in the pawn and if
the bishop moves back to D4 then of
course you have E5 trapping uh the
bishop and leading to
a very bad position for white
okay so C3 and now after the trade
basically the goal of my entire
operation has been achieved white is now
no longer able uh to Castle queenside
and now we redirect our Focus to the
center of the board and again I
implement this very typical idea Knight
D7 and we've seen this now three or four
times uh the game against trunsky the
title Tuesday game and every one of
those games I implemented this idea
where the Knight drops back the Knight
drops back to chase the bishop away the
bishop drops back in order to prepare E7
E5 blasting open the center okay so
Knight D7 Bishop F4 Bishop G7 and white
plays Rook to D1 which is a very clever
move so you might be asking well what
exactly happens if White Castle Queen
side like how do we actually win the
game how do we actually go about the
attack and probably there are multiple
ways uh but I would start with the move
Queen to A5 just deploying the queen and
aiming at some of White's weaknesses
let's say that white pushes G4 how would
you continue the attack on the queen
side here what is Black's best move
let's see who can find the most accurate
way to attack and as a small hint just
because you're attacking on the queen
side does not mean that every one of
your moves has to be geographically on
the queen side so the way that you
should think here is is say well it
would be very very nice if I could add a
rook to the B file this would
essentially spell disaster for white
well what's stopping me it's the bishop
the best move is E5 slicing away at The
Bishop's control over B8 now you can
even add the move C4 just forcing the
bishop to a more compromised spot and
Rook B8 ends the game and it ends the
game because there is no defense against
Queen A3 check and that's going to lead
either to Checkmate or in the best case
scenario for white White's going to lose
the queen and if white plays Queen D4 we
can even play Rook E8 and then Knight
takes E5 with just a massacre on all
sides of the board yeah just everything
is falling white can try to escape but
now the queen is caught in the middle
and in this line the queen is literally
trapped on D4 so hopefully that makes
clear to you that castling Queen side in
a situation like this is completely
unacceptable black is just going to go
for mate so for this reason our opponent
plays Rook D1 and I actually think
Bishop 7 is a very important move it
shows you that you have to have a lot of
patience and you have to really
understand at this high level what
exactly is the point of your opponent's
move if we had played E5 prematurely
then after d takes E5 Knight takes E5
there was the very nasty move Bishop E4
this was my opponent's idea tactical and
because our Rooks are not coordinated
we're not able to play D takes C4
because we dropped the
exchange so for that reason I decided to
first coordinate my Rooks and make sure
that D5 was protected because E5 is not
going anywhere he's not able to stop
this move and now it comes with a far
greater effect so our opponent goes for
the attack goes for G4 probably white
should accept that he is slightly worse
and just Castle King side but our
opponent understandably wanted to make
things happen on the king side so we
calmly play H takes G4 F takes G4 and
immediately strike in the center with E5
we don't have much time to waste because
H5 is is already coming and the attack
is going to get very dangerous in the
next couple of moves so we need to
strike first hence it's time for E5 okay
so Bishop G3 uh obviously if White had
taken uh we would have taken back on E5
threatening a fork on F3 and this would
be a disaster for white because D4 is
also coming uh with a discovered attack
against The Rook I think G4 was a
mistake that exacerbated and already bad
situation white is quite a bit worse
here after G4 I think white is already
borderline lost because the position
starts to fall apart so E5 Bishop G3 and
now another very patient move right Rook
E8 just increasing the pressure and
making sure that when the Center opens
up our pieces are going to be well
prepared for it there was no need to do
anything drastic like E4 or E takes D4
because we are not afraid of white
taking either one of our pawns we are
happy to embrace the tension okay so
White Castles King side now I identified
White's biggest weakness which is the G4
pawn and went directly for that pawn
with Knight F6 um the Tactical point is
that Bishop takes E5 is met with Knight
takes G4 Bishop takes G7 and now the
intermetzo queen takes H4 this was the
key I had to spot Queen takes H4 there's
a mate threat on H2 and if the bishop
drops back to E5 we take it with the
Rook Rook takes E5 reinforcing the mate
threat so this is a really important
line because just giving up the E5 Pawn
for nothing um made absolutely no sense
apparently White had to play H5 here in
order to generate counterplay but that
would have been a very difficult move uh
G5 is a lot more human and now we sink
our teeth into G4 hitting the E3 pawn
and finally we are prepared to open up
the center and just Massacre white on
all sides of the board Bishop B5 is just
a one move threat we just move the Rook
up and finally white buckles with dtes
C5 now one other very important subtlety
I think Queen C8 was the game-winning
Move If instead we had played Rook C8
what would have been the difference the
difference is that after C6 and a trade
on C6 and a trade on D5 after Knight
takes E3 white has the check on d8 this
is what I was trying to avoid uh by
putting my queen on C8 rather than my
Rook on C8 because here when the same
thing happens The Rook is now delegated
the task of defending the D 8 square and
this line works out so as I always say
at this very high level everything comes
down to Tactical details you can play a
brilliant positional game everything can
go right but if you miss a single
tactical detail everything goes into the
toilet so I had to calculate this line
because Rook C8 is a more natural move
trying to pick up the pawn of The Rook
but Queen C8 avoids the Tactical
problems so white played C6 anyway trade
on C6 and white position is now
collapsing Bishop F2 another very
patient move Rook d8 just getting
everything into the game making sure
that we don't lose an important center
pawn and now E4 carving a path for our
Knight to F3 and completely closing down
the
bishop of course if white would have had
gone E4 themselves uh we would have
played Rook e to D7 and if the defile
opens up then white loses very very
quickly Queen C2
and oh and there's a beautiful
combination here there is a beautiful
winning combination here black to play
Let's see if who can calculate the
entire winning combination uh which is
all forced incredible idea here I didn't
even see this during the game I just
kind of sensed that that there would be
a win here but I didn't see it oh my
gosh yeah it's trade everything trade
everything on D1 and I check on H1 and I
check on H1 incredible
yeah this is the classic spasy patran
combination deflection and Knight takes
D1 wow amazing the the kind of stem game
that uh has the most famous instance of
this combination is spasy versus petan
from one of their world championship
matches yeah okay so it was this
position just really really quickly this
isn't that that interesting but just so
you know the context and you know how
I'm able to quickly recognize these
patterns
because I've just seen a ton of games
okay white to play and finish the game
efficiently in this position so this is
from their 1966 World Championship match
okay I won't bore you to death here the
point is Bishop F7 oh sorry Bishop F7
Rook F7 and queen h8 same exact idea
luring the king to the vulnerable spot
and now you pick up the rook and the
Queen and you're up a piece uh so this
is kind of the stem game uh that
illustrates the theme and so for that
reason going back to our current game E4
lost the game by force our opponent was
forced to allow us to play E4 and now
once the Knight gets to F3 the game ends
immediately everything starts collapsing
everything starts crumbling and notice
that I kind of avoided all of the
unnecessary tactics so for example in
this position I think a lot of people
might start trying to calculate Queen E6
check oh maybe there's a beautiful mate
maybe I can get The Rook to the H file
but if there's zero necessity uh in
engaging in these lines you should avoid
them if you can just come back to F3 and
keep all of the advantages of your
position don't create unnecessary drama
don't calculate unnecessary tactics
particularly at these higher levels when
you're in time pressure just play the
simple chess Queen E6 Queen G4 getting
the queen in the attack getting the
bishop in the attack and uh the game
ends because the Knight literally has
nowhere to go notice that the G6 Pawn
also restricts the knight's forward
motion and after Rook G1 Queen
H3 we did not blunder Our Queen instead
we removed the defender and then picked
up the Rook on C1 lpdo loose pieces drop
off and the rest was pretty obvious okay
and that was the game so critical
moments we faced a Barry system
amazingly I've had this position already
twice first time in
2011 uh just keep in mind for the higher
rated players watching hopefully you
appreciated uh the theoretical
Exposition C5 is the more principled
move but I actually really like C6 I'm
pretty partial to this idea uh of
actually pushing
E5 uh so if you're a white player you
should probably go H3 against uh
C6 then this idea of Knight D7 and
Bishop G7 to prepare E5 is very
important uh we pushed before and C5 in
order to discourage white from castling
Queen side probably around here White
made a series of inaccuracies the engine
was giving Pawn Tak C5 as the best move
uh and the only way to keep the balance
and then Knight T Knight D7 Bishop to F4
so maybe C3 is actually a mistake
because once the queen side opens the
white king basically has nowhere to go
and then once the Center opens White's
kingside attack stops uh stops mattering
uh because white is unable to coordinate
their p pieces and then once we played
Bishop B7 very patient move and once E5
was played White's position starts to
crumble we were kind of patiently
improving our position Knight F6 was an
important move as well always relying on
small tactics and then of course Queen
C8 was another super important detail
and once this was taken care of White's
position just like slowly but surely
collapsed so that's how we were able to
win just uh of a slower positional game
but with a lot of tactical details
behind the scenes that hopefully I was
able to reveal uh we're going to end
here thank you guys thanks everybody and
thank you everybody for the support and
for making this content possible thank
you and I'll see yall later I'll try to
stream tomorrow uh maybe a little bit
[Music]
earlier